hey how's it going bros my name is peter
pan today we're starting a new
playthrough of a game called Katherine I
don't know much about this game to be
honest I feel like will will this will
be an experience we'll discover together
I know it's it's very story based but
it's also puzzle a puzzle game enjoy our
story by taking control of our torment
and main character and leading him to
freedom sounds amazing well I know also
the game has nice tits so that's that's
a game for me that's this my life sit
back and enjoy the stream tale we
haven't even started yet and I love it
there's there's Kirk eNOS and tits what
else do you want in life oh god they
started with a quote [ __ ]
there goes my 10 out of 10 rating
what is this
this is [ __ ] awesome this is so tight
that is giving me tense
now I totally get
set the ring
we were watching red sky fills with
glamour lovelies hello hello hello
Oh weights you good evening welcome to
the golden Playhouse thanks midnight
Venus tarisha like a really smart oh
yeah
is it in your cleavage you fall in a
dream and don't wake up before you land
you die in real life oh my GAD tonight's
story is Catherine an unconventional
romantic horror a man with a certain
curse has a terrifying week our hero in
this story his Vincent Brooks age 32
he's an earnest and kind man but one day
we begin to see him have terrifying
nightmares when we shot on top of that a
torrent a sweet seduction swoops down
upon him oh me all the blocks in his
life on the blocks outcome depends on
you viewers sorry to keep you waiting
raise the curtain / No enjoy the show
until we meet again
I know what you're thinking and no I'm
not wearing anything underneath here all
I want in life was to be an enemy
schoolgirl don't take that away from me
I love banning hey where'd you go
snap out of it were you even listening
sure you know you've been a little out
of it lately is everything all right
you've been spacing out left and right
oh sorry I had to work early this
morning this game is so [ __ ] anime
starring Vincent Broglie Catherine
mcbrick as Catherine really liked the
little bow ties I have mine yeah all I
know really is that you go through these
blocks as a puzzle to kind of get out of
the dream I think that's literally all I
know but it looks [ __ ] awesome so far
and I never seen any of the animation of
the game I just seem to pick up the tab
anyway
oh man I have a cold and it's disgusting
so you're welcome all right all right
all right here we go
a new adventure Bros are you ready why
do we have horns oh I get it
we're oh all right I love these
underwear
I bet there's people doing cosplay over
him I kind of want to cosplay
Stage one underground cemetery
okay I can move this how do I move hurry
up and climb I'm trying you save your
breath and start climbing if you fall
you're dead
oh [ __ ] die [ __ ] serious what about
my pillow the bottom of the stage is
falling it's so dramatic
okay I get it
there we go I'm climbing like doing it
daddy son are you proud of me daddy
saying I'm doing this for Symphony oh
god what now okay how am I supposed to
move these things you just push them
silly press the cross button the cross
who's that a sheep what is that easy
difficulty you can undo your last move
use it to give yourself a second why
would you say that I play on Normal
difficulty that's so weird
oh I didn't mean to today no I don't
wanna
amazing I'm such a puzzle genius hey I
get a pinup
okay mystic Bella make an effort to get
it it will be worth the effort that's
cool you know I like a good puzzle game
I just wish this game wasn't on PS and
you can put yourself into an impossible
situation
Oh collapse collapse laps around
carelessly can make things more
difficult for you okay first try pulling
a block to make some footing okay want
me to pull this oh my god I almost dead
it's like coins why am i collecting
coins oh [ __ ] I just did what they said
I wouldn't shouldn't do fantastic okay
I understand now I promise alright I got
it
I can tell me
please and support your weight even if
they're only touching by their edges
these bloggers normally they don't like
any things yeah what does that mean has
nothing directly under it as long as
it's touching an edge of another block
okay the edges glow bluish-white we make
it you bros understand man I'm such a
genius okay so I can push these blocks
fantastic
or should I say fabulous I'll be running
a long time yes is that what's bothering
you the most right now just get used to
it
just get used to her sister use the
edges to creep
I mean I can just walk up to we're
almost at the top rest as you knew the
top you will hear a bell ring
who's that guy talking to me okay
well this seems pretty straightforward
edge so honey my elements inch yeah we
did rap I'm joking he was [ __ ] creepy
as [ __ ] oh my god
I didn't sign up for a horror game Great
Escape
ah yes we'd better press
I can barely breathe in this outfit how
do i do me school girls do it this is
fun I like this game we got a gold look
at us a Afro try to make ask Joe Jesus
Christ what do you want
yay loading screen always awkward
arrogance
now man space tourism holy [ __ ]
terrible dream you doing looking in this
junk a lot of their story cutscenes what
am i poor pillow is this mysterious
pillow hello
but yeah yeah I'll be in today's code
review meeting really no no I'm just
just a little under the weather
no no it's okay I'll be right there
yeah um sorry V not gonna change these
on the word I can respect that you know
what all good
first thing for all this overtime you're
doing oh not this time this time do you
usually get overtime pay no so you don't
get anything he looks like a pug here
two sugars hey Catherine oh so she's
Catherine died you mean like where
you're in danger no no where you
actually died
you're being killed or something no I
usually do the killing in my dreams it
sounds like you how did we end up dating
a girl like this what's that supposed to
mean how many years have we been
together oh [ __ ] a relatable moment my
mother's been calling me up and asking
how we're doing
oh she's worried about me she knows I've
got a career that keeps me busy but yeah
I mean it's easy to keep things like
they are now but I don't know sometimes
Easy's best right I mean who knows
what'll happen in the future
I suppose Oh a little awkward there Oh
what that [ __ ] someone did die in their
sleep and in other news we have more on
the recent string of unexplained deaths
that seemed to be exclusively involving
young men cause of death is unknown and
while police are investigating
accidental causes foul play has
apparently not they change it the match
is on Catherine keeps telling me how her
mother's constantly calling her she says
she's not worried about it totally gonna
take it right Vinny what do you think so
come on pick one you kidding women's
wrestling what I know sounds to me like
she finally wants you to tie the knot oh
[ __ ] do you think so too
you don't want to marry your girlfriend
it's not that I love her but I don't
think we need to run out and get married
oh my god this is so relatable it's like
we're comfortable where we are exactly
our jobs always most important to her
she's always been the ambitious type
right it doesn't mean she'll always be
like that that's not what I mean besides
you're single - hey I'm still looking
for my soul mate not like you I've
already told my girl that I'm not
interested in marrying her what if you
never meet your soul mate then I'll
never get married what sounds just like
you chief anyway did you hear about Paul
he's dead Paul he's dead another guy we
saw I heard he just got divorced but he
looked healthy it's a complete shock
what happened to him I'm an accident I
don't know apparently his mother just
found him dead in his room this morning
you mean yeah the mystery death on the
news oh maybe we'll all wind up dead
tomorrow - hell of the news push their
agenda for ratings
Toby you are really easy to mess with
well speaking of crazy stuff this
morning I pissed the bed for the first
time since grade school I can't confess
that are you 32 I know that that was
really [ __ ] scared all right
I'm [ __ ] well into this he's skating
honestly
don't you have Catherine rate your hair
what does she see in this poor fool
sorry but I gotta be an early tomorrow
to much okay alright take care of Vince
see you later
[ __ ] stag I look so random I liked
how I played like three minutes in total
so far I know there's I have to set the
story or whatever actually
first aid station from your home you can
other change messages and save from a
phony okay it even reply to some
messages be sure to read them when they
come
oh okay what do we got check it on from
Catherine like I said before I'm having
dinner with some old friends it's
surprising most of them are already
married
oh and almost half of them have kids
they're all showing off pictures or
their families and it makes me feel left
out maybe it's time for us to get out of
the comfort zone too so we can we can
reply to that one and this is just that
oh my god what should we reply what how
do you my type
Oh does it bother you I worry about it
too sometimes maybe we should talk about
this goodnight alright seems fair enough
what was that rating thing oh man this
game is weird but I mean her ideas oh my
god that's awesome so you can play the
game differently what should we play
we'll just pick whatever I want
remember it it will affect the story oh
man that's awesome so there's a good
ending on a bad ending probably then
marriage I figured this would happen
eventually but just change jobs I'm
gonna give her trouble another message
congratulations you completed stage one
go to war your cell phone to take the
best score in stage one amazing Wow gold
price if you want attempted stage again
press to retry an image - Wow let's keep
going you had nothing to say about that
ha ha well I guess he doesn't remember
you got me another one it are you are
drinking at stray sheep again you know
you are you have work tomorrow geez take
it easy oh so I can choose to reply to
this should I reply to this let's see
what he says
guilty as charged I'll make sure I don't
drink enough to get a hangover take care
of yourself can I delete that last part
that seems stupid too
I find that seems fine to send too I
don't know [ __ ] skirt is going right
up my groin too much info got it all
right
no still feel like going home today
wait
it's very Japanese people really seem
like they never stay at home
they're like either at work or outside
you're about to go to the next scene
without safe sure you want to continue
without saving now I want to say
thank you very much I want to play a
little bit more come on
first day stray she
oh it reminds me of the shining a line
it feels inspired like my room is
serious where's the girl what's going on
Russ
alright brother I'm gonna have to end
that first episode there if you want
more go ahead and leave a like and we
would really appreciate it and supports
the series and I can keep going I'll
probably do it anyway but it's it's
always cool to see you bros your equally
excited or not and yeah I'll see you in
the next one as always stay awesome rest